my talk at the table is a powerful story
about the lasting impact of one person's
kind gesture claiborne elder a star of
the hit broadway musical company
recently sat down with our vlad dutier
to talk about his mission to give out
free tickets to his show elder wanted to
pay it forward after a stranger did the
very same for him 15 years ago he shared
his experience on social media and that
is where the story gets even better
i was pretty scared to move to new york
and
you know it really did seem like a big
scary city to me and not that this one
chance meeting of a stranger giving me
money changed everything for me but it
showed me a play that felt like
something i would be in
fifteen years ago claiborne elder was a
20-something from utah
[Music]
standing in the back of a broadway
theater watching putnam county spelling
bee when a random act of kindness opened
up a door
to new possibilities this man and woman
came up to me and said
hey are you from out of town and i said
yeah i'm just here visiting and the man
handed me 200 and said
you
looked like you were having more fun
than the people in the expensive seats
go buy yourself a ticket to sweeney todd
tomorrow it'll change your life he never
got a name just 200 bucks and this photo
hold on a second or even if you're in
your early 20s 200 bucks
you know the first thought is
i'm gonna hit the club
right for you i'm a theater nerd so i
was like how many rush tickets will this
buy no and actually you know what there
was part of that that when i got the
money i was like
i'm really i'm like really poor
yeah i could use this for a lot of other
things right and you've never seen
sweeney todd i'd never seen sweeney todd
i didn't really know it even that well
and uh
and so i did these are probably the
worst boys in london
starring in that production of sweeney
todd the legendary patty lupone and
speaking of feeling like broadway stars
were mythical that did not seem real
patti lupone seemed like a person you
read about in a book or heard about
somewhere but not someone you saw
perform
you know not for me not not for a kid
from utah
[Music]
what's even harder to believe
patty lupone is now his co-star you
could drive a person crazy
you could drive a person mad
a twist of fate that goes back to the
stranger who gave him the means to watch
one of broadway's biggest productions
it takes that kind of generosity
to show you what generosity can be to
turn it around and do it again
giving back is now a big part of clay's
life once a month he and his
four-year-old son pay for strangers meal
at their local diner and recently
through his social media he started to
give away free tickets to a show company
he posted it on instagram along with the
backstory of why
somebody asked for my venmo said i'd
like to send you some more money to buy
tickets he sent me seven hundred dollars
i don't know who i don't know him more
people started sending me money more
people started sending me money i'm
still giving away tickets i've given
away
150 tickets so far how much money have
people given you close to ten thousand
dollars what's even more
he found the stranger the minute he said
putnam county spelling bee
it all came back his name is mark howell
and he lives in la we got to be there
for their first zoom reunion it's been
really overwhelming and i couldn't talk
about this for the first three days
without you know sobbing it's been
really inspiring
and and overwhelming like it's still you
know makes it really does it makes me
cry you know the what's amazing about a
random act of kindness and is the
randomness of it you had no idea that
what you did
was so much more than that
and
made me a person who is kinder
because of what you did when you learned
that strangers just like you
had given clay
upwards of ten thousand dollars to do
what you did
how does that make you feel it's
humbling
and that's all i can say is it's really
humbling through clay all of those
people who were motivated
toward a similar act of generosity
buying tickets for strangers
it changes their soul
it changes their soul just a little bit
you know
now every performance clay takes a
picture with all the strangers he buys
tickets for and hangs it in his dressing
room i hope that it awakens something in
them just like it did in me that these
people are shown some sort of genuine
kindness from a stranger
and hopefully in turn go out and do
something strange and kind for somebody
who they don't know
vlad
i love that awesome story we all like
get the tissues only because it was so
beautiful and so
kind to lack of a better word may we all
do something like that but do you know
why he did it to be the the guy who gave
him yeah mark wow because he saw he saw
clay watching
this musical and something about the
look on his face the joy
the longing the inspiration just
inspired him to offer this 200
i could not stop talking to claiborne
elder he is an amazing individual yeah
and now he's playing i now want to go
see that play i know i know i want to go
see him see clay i'm
people are doing wonderful things every
day right do something strange and kind